electronic arts EA starting their crazy
III shindig on Monday and 1pm it's going
to be eight and nine o'clock if you're
in the UK and Ireland and I have a
lovely handsome couch damn hines DC
James Roberts crossly oh thank you very
much for making all the ways to our Sam
cisco office from your respective
islands everywhere else let's talk about
EA first of all this morning we actually
got a little bit of VA news already
Mirror's Edge a catalyst yeah it's not
going to be called mirrors edge 2 it's
going to be called catalyst and I think
the reason why they're doing that is
because this is not going to be a direct
sequel okay saying they're saying this
is calling it's not a remake no reboot
it's just a margin story yes I look at
me today just giving themselves a chance
just try and do it again yeah you know I
think it's really cool because if you if
you look at the first message I mean I
think people thought it was a little bit
flawed think everyone thought that the
second hat the gun stuff the guns
download The Herald hasn't it but also
it in cell a2 Daria so it's pretty cool
for EA to go just try again see what
happens so faith is the protagonist in
this again yes but it's not a sequel not
a prequel they're just gonna go that
they're gonna George Lucas this and just
like yeah we're just making it happen
ever have in the edge that's fair enough
as you reckon we'll see gameplay at this
conf listen I think we'll definitely see
gameplay this has been environment for
more than two years now so yeah I think
I think we'll see a lot of game player
it's amazing how they were confident
enough to show like gray box gameplay
last time and just yeah concept stuff so
hopefully we'll see some more you know
final complete stuff this night another
game we'd like to see a lot of gameplay
ivano Lucy you certainly looking forward
to this mass effect 4 oh it's got to be
why it's the last year they had the the
behind-the-scenes developers all in a
really dark room yeah the most
frustrating tease ya ever I was SAT
there in the press conference and they
didn't really announce it and then the
music stopped everyone in the room just
went and then you know Casey Hudson
comes on and they talk about their grand
ideas and now if CKC Hudson's at
Microsoft but you know it's the court
it's the team at
why we're Montreal so it's not even the
Edmonton guys who are working on
mysterious Project X yeah I'm really
excited i think at this stage it's gonna
be i really hope they don't cop out and
do your CGI trailer hmm i really hope
its gameplay obviously they had that
leak quite recently so thing is everyone
saying is it real is it not real the
thing is that the same thing happened
with borrow the Dragon Age Inquisition
and that leak of the survey and what
actually we got with dragon age
inquisition was very very similar like
90 minus the leap that happened with
mass effect so it was a like a marketing
survey that came up i think someone
posted it to reddit and it was basically
the plot of the game is gonna be years
after Shepherd's endeavors you know
whichever anything you got you are a
pathfinder it's basically passed on
won't occur ok again is great because
you're searching for a new home for
humanity yeah so you're searching you're
clearing you're in the under ama de casa
you're clearing places putting
settlements in they can mind think
civilization beyond Earth Battlestar and
I really hope that I mean it sounds
graded and they've got the multiplayer
coming back from us like three they've
got the horde mode if this is true it
sounds like a big game is a big ROG and
even from the stuff that we saw they
were saying you know it's going to be x
times bigger than mass effect 3 you can
go from space oh you know the new ship
is apparently called The Tempest so you
can go from The Tempest to the Mako and
then like land again make us back me
make a new maker I like to make oh I'm
gonna make all colleges I like the maker
was alright that's good fun yeah land
land on the planet's surface seamlessly
without a wow you know i watched
interstellar recently i want from this
it's just that sense of going out into
the unknown and actually exploring a
galaxy which was kind of in Mass Effect
1 my god I've got more familiar with the
galaxy you sort of lost that you're
right do you think actually gonna see
gameplay though because obviously last
year they just show some developers
talking about the game which means
probably really early in development
right if they tease this for I guess you
probably could get away with it but it
would be a massive shame I like it yes
if they've been doing since mass effect
3 and all its DLC ship mhm
put that question to you newsman figure
it out I like this in a static idea yeah
I like idiot game finishes once you find
like a crying what's his name again Matt
Damon yes hahaha the love transcends
time and space oh god no that's not
that's not they almost had it and we
mentioned Star Wars earlier star wars
battlefront Chris and Rob went to see it
a couple of months ago and they SAT them
down and showed them a CG trailer and
then the most scripted single-player
sequence i think i've ever heard of huh
and what do you guys think about
battlefront looking forward to it I'll
be about some viet nam phan you know i
think that um this is going to be the
first time we see the star wars universe
rendered with such high detail and it's
kind of something that we need for Star
Wars because it's got such a gritty
dirty lived-in feel and the games have
felt quite sterile and clean up until
now so that's it Shing so you think it's
a situation where the technology with
the movies has gone in one direction and
the games have never really been able to
like emulate it yeah because games look
fake you know like and this is this you
can see now like that looks like a
forest yeah mm-hmm that's apparently in
marin so that's the same forest that the
planet of the apes monkeys are running
around speaking of returning properties
need for speed who was the need do you
have any drop Crossley not really
feeling Lucy do of the needs always have
the need does being I was a huge on the
ground fan yeah I was an underground on
the ground what about before was cool
before was fun this basically looks like
on the ground three yeah I don't know
why they're not even calling it
underground three because doesn't matter
what everyone actually wants so it
sounds cool I just want to race cars
with some sweetening on underneath so
yeah thanks Ross will see some gameplay
the sagorn the apparent is that they
said apparently this is an engine in
engine with a who not even knows what
that means anymore yeah my camera would
be a lot still yeah yeah there's nothing
a camera with people like more than fake
each other on the trailers and let's get
into the stuff we don't know really know
about Lucy your dragon age from you
think you'll see anything
new on the they have said there is new
dlc coming so the first bit of story bit
bc ously just hit play station sadly oh
I'm kind of disappointed with this
because it got on xbox and then the
witcher 3 came out mmm and then it got
to play station yes I feel like they've
just sort of knocked that market on the
head there is more soy-based dlc coming
and i think they said you're not
necessarily playing as the Inquisitor
okay do you think is ruin people's lives
for the witcher and dragon at same time
yeah like mathematical logistical II I
don't like but that is generally my
reason that I haven't played yet because
you know Carol review um but i think
this if at least if it's not dlc hmm is
it too late in the day for dlc i guess
if you've gone to the you know father
actually creating hope this stage you
just need to put it out cuz bio sdlc has
it ever had a press conference showing
its really anticlimactic thing to show
to press conference true yeah maybe
they're just trying to prove it's
definitely not on disk yeah we'll have
to wait and see and getting back into
the rumor pile there was an earnings
call for EA number of months ago one of
the things that popped up there apart
from Mirror's Edge actually which we
never seen confirmed was a some new
plants vs zombies game you kind of have
to put good money out of garden warfare
2 and we look forward to new PVC game
that first one was actually it was
actually right like it was fun it was a
game that no one asked for but it was
still all right yeah and now we live in
a post splatoon worlds where apparently
first-person shooters or that was it was
a third person mostly I guess but that
type of market is kind of like open to
the idea that was a really great III
reveal as well because you could like it
was a live gameplay demo and then but my
favorite thing about it was the guy at
the end who came up and just went but
yes hey peggle 2 on ipad yes you know
been a while it eventually did come out
on the playstation 4 so how I go to on
all the platforms its event what if
plants vs zombies garden warfare 2 had a
cinematic single-player campaign oh my
god that'd be [ __ ] brilliant
so to be [ __ ] like where it is like
the protagonist is a plan yet or a
zombie you see from there both
perspectives and they meet at the end in
Stalingrad oh my god that'll be pretty
great and what else we got here probably
stuff on the indie front but let's take
a jump to we did talk about star wars
game earlier of course Amy Hennig left
Naughty Dog yeah helma star wars star
wars game do you think it's a bit early
to see that I think it's a bit too early
Amy Hennig was working on the Uncharted
series and I think she sure wants to
leave her mark on on the games that she
makes and I think yes it's way too early
I thing that's still probably in the
pre-production yeah I mean stages what
they do when they did last year when
show developers in a darkened room yes
saying the game still exists I don't
think you ain't get out with two star
wars games but what the press conference
though that's a good point and I think
it's a brief mention and then
Battlefront yeah I think that's actually
a really good point I think you know
battlefront is going to be the biggest
game absolutely their biggest game is
their biggest bet this year so not only
talking about other Star Wars games
they're probably not only talking about
be talking about battlefield either
right they'll probably have to just
leave that for sure I guess delegate
their dice will be busy talking about
mirrors edge so I'll probably keep them
educated and that's basically a Fourier
except we should probably mention it's
probably gonna be a new FIFA I believe
this year they've been looking for the
shoes there's a new FIFA that's actually
pretty great that they finally bothered
to put ladies football in that's great
so we saw this trailer come out of
course the world cup is on at the moment
and on artificial grass which is a bit
bloody ridiculous but we're going to see
12 teams I think from the International
Women's seen this is something I think
they're testing to see if they can
expand it as an arsenal fan our Arsenal
ladies team has been prolific destroyed
the Premier League or the past decade
over so it'll be cool to see this stuff
expand and then of course Madden we'll
see probably presumably some sort of NHL
situation NBA you got any more acronyms
its goal NHL and yet I said that MLB
wait oh sorry they have UFC MLG EA
sports UFC that's right yeah we do have
you been a conor mcgregor you know i'm
honestly surprised you're not selling
the women's fifa as a separate product
could you imagine could you imagine if
that yeah because they did with basic
like world cup games forever and it's
weird they sort of go either side and
that sometimes they do this DLC pack
sometimes they actually put the mat as
their own products yeah and yeah at the
very least being a it is a bit funny
into this DLC yeah but yeah that's all
EA goodness we're going to have that is
on Monday 1 p.m. pacific which is nine
o'clock BST if you're aware not part of
the world make sure to catch it all on
gamespot com